- [Narrator] The idea of
robots taking human jobs
might bring to mind a scene like this.
But it's not hardware
that has white collar workers concerned.
It's rapidly advancing software,
since artificial intelligence
is doing a lot more
than finishing emails.
- Perhaps the biggest nightmare
is the looming new industrial revolution.
- The erosion of the middle class.
Already one of America's
most serious problems,
could get much worse
with AI if we ignore it.
- [Narrator] Here's how AI
is already taking over tasks
at white collar jobs, and
why employees and companies
are both excited and concerned
for the future of work.
Generative AI can auto
complete your sentences,
write feature length films,
or organize your calendar.
And tools using it like ChatGPT
are taking on an increasing
role in white collar work.
They can create first drafts of documents,
presentations, images,
video, and product designs.
Currently, 25% of work
tasks could be automated
by AI in the US according
to Goldman Sachs research.
Generative AI helped make
this ad, and this one too.
The company advertised here
said creating the image
for this AI generated ad
cost about 10 times less
than traditional methods.
- This works much in the same
way as other kinds of AI,
which are using statistical methods
on large amounts of data,
processing that through
computational power,
and then generating out
a computer vision system
that says this image looks
a lot like these other cats
that I've been trained on.
Generative AI is
functionally very similar.
- [Narrator] It goes
beyond creating images.
Alphabet is now using AI to run
anti-money laundering
surveillance programs
at banks like HSBC, and says
it's cutting out human error.
- [Presenter] And when
the transactional data
and illicit behaviors change, as they do,
so does the AML AI engine.
- [Narrator] For some tech companies,
AI is contributing to job cuts.
A May report said nearly
4,000 tech workers
lost their jobs to AI.
Artificial Intelligence is also
eliminating future positions.
Take IBM as an example.
Its CEO said the company
could replace workers with AI.
- I do believe that AI
is going to replace a lot
of what I'm calling white
collar clerical jobs.
So the ones that are much more repetitive,
the ones that people do the same task
again and again and again,
I think a good 30% of those roles
could go away over five years.
- Companies are making
evaluations about future hiring
on the basis of what they project
AI to be capable of doing.
That's a much more tenuous area.
- [Narrator] An IBM
spokesman said the company
was still hiring for
thousands of positions.
- I think that what we've
seen in past deployments of AI
is that it's frequently used
as a justification for layoffs,
but it doesn't necessarily mean
that it is effectively replacing
what human workers are capable of,
or that it's increasing
workers' productivity.
- [Narrator] Dropbox laid off
16% of its workforce in April,
but not to replace workers.
Like IBM, it said it wanted
to invest more in AI,
which meant cutting elsewhere.
- So we see demand growing for
these products a lot faster
than we could have anticipated,
and I think you could have
seen the technology coming
but just the way that the
interest went vertical
is something that's way ahead of schedule
from our expectations.
- [Narrator] At OpenAI, execs
say there may be more work.
- I think that like the kind of sum total
of what is going to be needed
to make use of the technology
as a maximally productive technology,
and kind of inflect
that productivity curve
up in the world will actually require
more man hours on top than you think.
- But across industries,
workers and executives
are cautiously looking ahead.
AI's role in television
and film production
is a key point of negotiations
between the Writers Guild
of America and the studios.
(protesters chanting)
Speaking to the "Wall Street
Journal" about the strike,
the co-showrunner for
the "Handmaid's Tale"
laid out the writers union's concerns.
- You know, we could tell
from the negotiations
that the studios wanted, to had a plan,
and we could deduce that
that plan was probably
one writer in a room
with one or two machines
creating an entire show.
- [Narrator] Studios have
said they're committed
to discussing the use of AI with the WGA.
- The WGA strike I think is
a really important moment
to be paying attention to because
it's a place where workers
have taken the forefront in putting AI
at the front and center
of their negotiations
about their working conditions.
- If it's coming for us, the
creators of imaginary worlds,
it is literally going
to come for everyone.
- [Narrator] But there may
still be time to figure out
how to best integrate
AI into the workplace.
- So I think it's really important
that in the present
moment, we preserve space
for a public conversation
around the deployment
of AI systems that ensures
that they're working
in the public interest,
in workers' interest,
and as well as in employers' interest.
(upbeat bright music)